Nói lại chỉ kiện thoại đại chiếc, là mắt tại đi dương tru quốc ở tần trước.
Và trên tay tôi là 1 trong 8 sản thẩm độ tiên có mặt lại trình Việt Nam.
Và đó, chỉ kiện thoại của kánh tay đồ vô đồ thế này rồi.
Hò nợ, đồ vô phổ.
Tính năng hồi bệnh nhất ở chiếc lại hệ thông trấu dung dạc kánh tay đồ vô có thể kéo dài và thực hiện nhiều dương năng.
Bản thân gí bồ sẽ được chăng bị một cái cảm biển nạn rất là lớn, lồ phần dại hai sang bị kai biết sao.
Và theo dân nghiệm ngang của tôi rất là tất cả các cái cảm mệt ra trên biển thoại thông mình khác.
Một tính năng khác theo tôi thấy là tụi vị, thì như nó có lẽ là cái tự tế này sẽ không cao lắm.
Lỡ là ki bồ này có thể đống vai cho giống như kéo đồ mốt.
Có thể nhảy bố mà nói chuyện.
Điều này sẽ thử tổ ý, cái sự sống vật cái tránh nghiệm nói chuyện với định thoại.
Bố có phần nhằm chán thì chúng ta nói chuyện với các cái trởi hảo.
A lạy khác như là ZMina, Chá ZMT.
Tuy nhiên, điều là tổ năng rất là phần này.
Có lẽ không nhiều người để ý.
Nó là mấy là một chức hiện thoại được tập trung rất nhiều và khả năng qua video.
Thì nó hợp tác với nhảy cho tất cả bí để nạn chuyến nghiệm nói là A rồi rồi.
A điều này có nghĩa là đồ mốt phôn sẽ được chẳng bị cái mạng qua video lúc sê và góc.
Kêu chính mẫu lúc, các cái trí đồ, để nạn chuyến nghiệm, giúp cảnh qua gì giống như được qua mằng mái qua A rồi rồi, thì thực thu.
Tuy nhiên khi sẽ giống tục tế để tòa thì có một cái bình đẹp.
Này thì tổ đánh nghĩ rằng anh khi mà hòa rồi ra mắt đồ bốt phôt, nó là trọng lượng của nó khá lớn.
Các bạn hãy xem buồn với tám gói làm một con số thách thức khá lớn với một chiến thạc của mạng thì sau phía đây.
Tuy nhiên, đây là một điều dễ hiểu.
Bởi vì là đồ bốt phôn, có rất nhiều lý kịch khác nhau là việc tình cho kể chi tiết, giúp bù, các mấy đà như thế này.
Mày tình mới là với cảnh trại đồ bốt.
Thì trước, các bạn có này cũng là một chiếc phát xí cào cấp của họ nở ở màn hình sau phía đây, có lất phủ trong đó phía trước.
Mày ra thì một đẹp này của có có phíang rất mạnh với chiếp xí lý, khác là gần thám, élis, ra năm.
Và một nếu ra mùi râm thì có thể tuy trọng lên tới là mùi sau khi bà, và một nếu, ra chồng là lên tới 1 tế tà bà.
Bà, một đẹp này của sởi vì một phía rất là lớn.
Mày nghĩ thúc trọng sống người như thế giới có thể cho chúng ta sự đục khá ngại.
Nếu nó được bán tảy hình bên nào với một giá tinh tự, thì chúng có có là phạm muốn người đến năng người cho đầu.
Thì bạn có một giá yếu trước, đúng không có phủ này không?
Hai để lại bị đợp bên dưới nhá.
Thì nhào và hay đợp lại.